Welcome to this 170th commencement ceremony of
Hillsdale College thank you for coming let us
remember to be grateful for the blessings of the
Lord upon this college which have been abundant
the ceremony is on the occasion of the graduation
of the seniors, but it's not just about them
it took everybody here to produce this ceremony.
Take the faculty and the work they have done to
lead us through the things we need to know because
of what we are. They live with the students,
they laugh with them, they eat with them, they
cry with them. The parents are important this
room is full of parents swelled with pride
they spend a third of their lives or more
taking care of these young people and what they
give to their children is everything they've got.
There are friends of the college here they support
the college everybody in this room and everybody
watching is part of the achievement
that we're here to celebrate today.
As a group and individually these seniors are the
best we ever had and I went back in my notes from
last year and verified that I said that last year
too and it was true both years and I expect it
will be true next year you get a year to be top
of the heap but you are awesome people and you
will be greatly missed here except you are not
leaving after all you're going to live the life
that you have prepared yourself to live and
you're going to live it in contact with this
college which is a partnership that includes you.
You seniors new graduates you're at a pinnacle
of sorts that's one metaphor pinnacle
another how about a crossroads
the metaphor works because you make a decision
you go one direction or another and there's an
old blues idea that you meet the devil at the
crossroads at midnight and then you might ask
well why do you meet the devil at the crossroads
and the answer is most fundamentally because
when you come to a place in your life where
you have to make a choice you aim up or down
and so you know you're called upon to to
take the lessons that you've been taught in
a university like this that that teaches you to
abide by the eternal verities to sacrifice your
own narrow pretensions in the highest sense to
something that's truly better anything you pursue
that isn't that is insufficient. You're a
particularized creature as a son of God or
a daughter of God let's say you have something to
bring into the world that no one else can bring in
and so if you fail in that duty
then you deprive the world of that
there's no shortage of suffering in life and
no one thinks their own suffering isn't real
and maybe there's a possibility that
there's some aim that's so high that
the attempt alone to move in that direction is
of sufficient value to act as a panacea for the
suffering and so you could say at the end of your
life oh my God that was so hard it was worth it
and so that's the choice you make at
the crossroads if you have any sense.
Now at our freshman convocation, Dr.
Arnn told us to get your boots on
we have to have this inherent desire
to learn and to expand our knowledge
Hillsdale's given that to us. Here at Hillsdale
we are meant to be together as a family
and more importantly we are meant to achieve
self-government together and along the way
you'll set down a path and live an example for
others to follow for the same end in other words
keep your boots on. I was
going to speak more extensively
but Dr. Jordan Peterson covered most of
the topics I had planned to talk about
Actually I am here in my capacity my proud
capacity as chairman of the board of trustees
of Hillsdale college and I'm representing the
board when I first of all thank the graduates
for all they have brought to this campus over the
last several years you have not only received a
world-class education you've learned what it takes
to be a good and effective citizen you spend time
thinking about and talking about the good and
the true and the beautiful all that is inside
you now and it's just up to you to get out
there and shine a light on the world. From
all of us here again congratulations to the
170th graduating class of Hillsdale college.